If a student
is striving and struggling to pass his
examination in Arabic, we'll say he's
doing jihad.
So jihad basically means to strive and
struggle.
Most of the people think whether Muslims
or non-Muslims, they think that jihad
can only be done by Muslims. A
non-Muslim cannot do jihad.
Allah says in the Quran
in a couple of verses in a couple of
places in the Quran that even
non-Muslims did jihad. Allah says in
surah Lman chapter number 31 verse
number 14 we have enjoined on the human
beings to be kind to the parents in
triple in travail over travail did the
mother bore you and in years twain was
your
next verse. So Lukman chapter number 31
verse number 15 says but if your parents
do jihad strife and struggle to make you
worship somebody else besides Allah of
which you have no knowledge do not
follow them but live with them with love
and companionship. Here Allah is saying
is talking about non-Muslim parents
doing jihad
nobody else besides Allah.
So yeah, Allah uses the word in the
Quran as jihad that non-Muslim parents
are doing jihad
struggling and striving to make their
children worship somebody else besides
Allah. A similar message is repeated in
surah Ankabud chapter number 29 verse
number eight. We have enjoined other
human beings to be good to their
parents.
But if your parents strive and struggle
to jihad to make you worship somebody
besides Allah, do not obey them. Here
again the message is repeated in surah
an kabud chapter number 29 verse number
8. Allah is talking about non-Muslim
parents doing jihad striving and
struggling to make the children
worship somebody else besides Allah. The
word jihad is used here. The jihad done
by the non-Muslims is
jihadan.
Jihad in the name of shaitan. Satan that
means they're striving and struggling to
please the Satan. What we Muslims do is
jihad.
Jihad striving and struggling in the way
of Allah.
Now whenever jihad is used unless
otherwise the context speaks something
else it is understood it is jihad
striving and struggling in the way of
Allah
unless the context speaks something else
like in surah lman chapter 31 verse
number 1415 of surah ankab 29 verse
number 8 the context shows you that the
non-muslim parents are striving and
struggling in the way of satan
And it's otherwise generally when you
use the word jihad it means
striving and struggling in the way of
Allah.
Most of the non-Muslims and some
so-called Muslim scholars inverted
commerce they translate the word jihad
as holy war.
If you translate the English words holy
war into Arabic it is harbumdasa.
This Arabic words
does not appear anywhere in the Quran
neither in any authentic hadith. It's
not there.
So to say that holy war that jihad means
holy war is wrong. Mukadasa doesn't
appear anywhere in the Quran nor in the
hadith nor in the things of the prophet.
This English word holy war was first
used
centuries ago to describe the crusaders,
the Christian crusaders who in the name
of Christianity killed thousands and
tens and hundreds of thousands of human
being. You accept Christianity or you're
killed. And they called it the holy war.
So this holy war which was used
for the crusaders, the Christian
crusaders to kill non-Christians if they
don't accept Islam
is now used for the Muslims
is totally wrong. No way does the Quran
or the hadith the saying of the prophet
uses the word of Dasa. So jihad does not
means holy war. Jihad means to strife
which means to struggle.